[Music]
what is up Maddon fans I am your host
Adam rank nobody one person applause
break I wanted a bigger pop than Trevor
Noah but that's okay I'm still stoked to
be here live from EA play here in Los
Angeles now back at the NFL Draft we
revealed a ton of new features coming to
Madden 20 since then we've been asking
what you the fans want to see well guess
what we've heard those results and they
were overwhelmingly clear you guys want
rake in the game I mean the game I don't
know if I'm not I'm not in the game I'm
sorry no we got game play we're gonna
give you actual gameplay that's coming
up in just a moment we'll be bringing
you your first look and Madden gameplay
that the ones that you've been asking
for but right now upfront we're gonna do
a quick recap of five awesome new
features coming to bat in 20 and show
you even more details let's open things
up with face of the franchise the brand
new career campaign that allows you to
create a so you can pop for that that's
cool it's a cool feature you'll be able
to create a superstar quarterback select
one of 10 d1 schools and compete in the
college football playoffs and speaking
of super star quarterbacks we sat down
with NFL MVP and Madden 20 cover athlete
Patrick mahomes to hear more about his
superstar journey I've always loves
competing and to me there's no added
pressure there's no added expectations
that stuff that I put on myself since I
was a little kid I feel like I'm just
that same guy that's been putting in the
time and the work my whole entire life
now it's about pushing myself every
single day to get better it's about
passion I'm going out there having fun
you have to make sure that you're just
evolving never being satisfied with
where you're at coming to the league it
seems like every single year there's
some different guy that's just faster
and stronger and figure and so with the
find different ways to get better and
those are the guys that find ways to win
in the end every single year from
college to come into league and as my
career goes on I just keep getting
better and better
the approach from each play and
recognized what you can do it have
success the first time I ever ran out
the tunnel in front of that crowd it was
a surreal feeling and I'll never forget
it my expectation was to win a Super
Bowl
and I fell just short of that you used
that stuff as motivation this is just
the beginning oh wow Patrick mahomes
give it up he's amazing he's an amazing
quarterback he's living the journey that
you'll be taking on in face of the
franchise and joining me right now is
Matt and community manager Israel Cruz
aka agent K figure it's a little more
information on face of the franchise as
well as some of the other exciting
features that are coming to get what are
you doing hey it's great to be you know
you look a little crispy up top and you
know me too so I brought you some all
that way but uh yeah seven and
three-quarter although there's a guy in
a cleome actor take off the Chiefs cap
put this on hey there you go don't give
away though you gotta protect the noggin
man thank you so much you know over the
last few weeks we've been talking about
Matt and 20 on live streams and it's
been great our community has been really
engaged and we've been asking them
questions what do you want to see here
at EA play and this is the culmination
we took their feedback we're gonna talk
a little bit about those things and
regarding face of the franchise
our players want to see an NFL draft
experience what's going on so you'll see
when one of these screens right here
what's really great is you're going into
the NFL draft sequence right here you're
in the green room you know your players
a little bit nervous representing that
Texas Longhorns go horns and
cheeseburger right there so yes it's
still Los Angeles the Rose ball from a
couple years ago it's still looming
large though so be cool with that well
listen don't get mad at me just stop
Vince Young all right so here's the
thing so what so this is all awesome I
love the detail there once you get
drafted what you're now in franchise
mode and all that stuff and I hear the
Pro Bowl is coming back to what else
should Madden fans now yes it's really
cool the Pro Bowl is back in Madden 20
when you're going to go and install the
game you're going to be able to play the
Pro Bowl get your
hands on those superstar X Factor's play
with them a little bit but our franchise
players are one to see more about the
scenario engine and we're going to show
a little bit about that now the scenario
engine what it does it brings dynamic
quests kind of dynamic challenges into
the game that help you improve your
player and their ratings week to week so
that's pretty awesome but you said it
earlier people want to see more about
gameplay so we're gonna go ahead and
talk about gameplay and start a blog
where they can check all that stuff out
there yes there is we've written quite a
few blogs we have gridiron notes which
you can go ahead and search the web
you'll find those but we also have a
franchise deep dive blog that details
everything out coming to franchise in
man 20 okay for all the play callers and
armchair coaches what else can they look
forward to you know like real estate
it's like location location location
people want playbooks play books
playbook scores now this year Madden 20
we're having RPO is coming into the game
with your run pass options which looks
great but not just that but our players
have been asking for new formations so
right here we have out of the Raiders
playbook unique formation which that's
which is actually called double a single
back double off close and what's great
about this is a PA sweep play we've got
going on right here which is absolutely
great our players are excited about that
but what I'm excited about is that
throughout the course of the season
we're gonna go ahead and evolve those
play books and as things happen in the
NFL we're gonna bring that stuff to the
NFL yeah I see the one Derek Carr fan
out there was very excited to see that
Raiders playbook and I know that we've
got a lot of I'm sorry two Raider fans
wear jersey next time I can't identify
you without it it's okay listen I'm
talking to Israel though here's the
thing now we've got a lot of mattad
ultimate team fans in the house am i
right they want to know more about the
content that you're gonna be bringing to
the table tell us a little bit more
about those ultimate missions yeah so
ultimate missions are great a lot of
times our madden ultimate team players
when they log into the game they're
always trying to find the most
up-to-date content so one of the things
this year that we're trying to do is
provide them kind of a guide and
information hub so then when they log in
they're not spending all that time
looking in different areas they can get
the player items that they want for
their team to make the best squad
possible hey hey hey hey I heard that
so one of the things that's absolutely
great let's say Khalil Mack has
in game on Sunday you know you log into
Madden as long as I'm mad no to a team
you want to be able to find it so
basically we're gonna go ahead and
provide you that information guy that
step-by-step process so you can get that
item on your team now the Clio Mac fan
sitting here loves here and that the
guys the two Raider fans over here not
so much whatever we appreciate a little
switching guys I know that's talking
about the Rose Bowl being too soon
yeah we love the Raiders I love John
grit and what he's done for our team now
the most thing that the thing that I'm
most excited for though is the superstar
x-factor abilities these make the
superstars you know play like superstars
and eager you're gonna give us a little
bit of a reveal and some of these
abilities yeah so our players have been
asking us to go ahead and talk about
these super star X factors the first one
we're gonna reveal is alvin kamara
which is great is he has his own
abilities he also has superstar
abilities and we're gonna go and take a
look right here what's cool about his
own abilities called satellite you've
you've heard a satellite Baxter I know
what it is yeah okay so yeah I mean
these guys yeah so at the end of the day
I mean you know you guys have seen the
tape out of the backfield Kamara's a
deep threat as a wide receiver as a
receiver just it's crazy he's absolutely
amazing out of the backfield but he also
has superstar abilities so the superstar
abilities are matchup nightmare so
basically you're gonna go ahead have
better opportunities to go ahead and
catch the ball against linebackers and
DBS and also better route running
I mean he's absolute beast and he also
has running back apprentice well running
back apprentice actually does for him is
that it allows him to have four
additional hot routes anytime and
pre-play adjustments love that now
listen everybody who knows me knows I'm
kind of a dumb guy so can you explain
the difference between zone abilities
and superstar abilities yeah so for zone
abilities we talked about satellite so
what it's gonna happen is in game you're
gonna go ahead and get some in-game
objectives on how to go ahead and get
your player in the zone and you know
Clint's gonna talk a little bit here
about how you knock them out of the zone
but the thing is is that superstar
abilities what that's going to allow you
to do is that it's it's they're always
available they're always on and not just
that but it brings like a unique
authentic feel to that specific player
so what Kamara
one of the things that we were actually
showing right there is that it's going
to allow him to go ahead and do some
amazing things out of the backfield it's
just another level of authenticity is
what's everything
totally
our players have been asking us for a
long time they want the players to feel
like nfl superstars when they're on the
field and we want to give that to them
okay now to help us get even more down
and dirty and some of those details on
x-factor abilities
I want everybody right now this is
serious put your hands together because
joining us here on the stage here in
just a moment is one of the best wide
receivers on the planet from the
Pittsburgh Steelers from the University
of Southern California a hardcore mad
and fed ladies and gentlemen all the way
in the back give it up for juju Smith
Schuster
[Applause]
[Applause]
there it is the crowd loves juju right
[Applause]
you guys oh my goodness you know what
thank you so much for coming out it we
always appreciate you taking the time
and interacting with the community and
everything how are you enjoying your
time here at EA play I'm loving it it's
awesome it's a blessing to be here you
see the fans and Stoller fans look at I
was here last year and it was amazing
setup and to come back again no question
and you know I heard about Madden 20 and
I heard about paddle homes being on the
cover and a whole extract their thing
and I was like wow this is amazing
now you mate you had a monster year once
again you know you're obviously one of
the best players in the league kind of
go through the thought process when
you're on the field you're in zone you
see single coverage what are you
thinking when I see that one-on-one it's
the opportunity of me getting the ball
you know knowing that the defense is
coming and what if I have to put the
wall a lot faster and all I can think of
my head is I catch the ball get yak yard
score touchdown celebrations and pretty
much in my hair I'm just like wow like
let's make a play big place and you make
big play what do you had a 97 yard
reception or did you have - yeah -
that's right I'm sorry to mean to sell
you sorry now in addition to getting all
those yak yards you're also known for
wrestling away those jump balls so it's
no surprise to me that your zone ability
is double me is it cool if we take a
look yeah check it out
yeah so what you guys are gonna see
right here with Jude you said once he
gets in that single coverage and he is
in the zone there is no stopping him the
only way that you're gonna be able to
stop him is to go ahead and double cover
and at the end of the day you know it's
a it's a new meta to the game if you
want to stop juju you got a double cover
them well first of all you can't stop
them let's just put that out there right
now what did you think do you think we
nailed it what do you thought Sasa
Matt's crazy that's definitely something
I you know I see myself doing you know
the double coverage stretching this year
to be super exciting and I just can't
wait you're not having to xpect I can't
wait to you know use it in the game use
myself in the game are you ready to
check it out II excited to start playing
super excited all right well you're in
luck because we've got mad and twenty
playable right here at EA play you an
agent cake and go try it out agent K is
there any way that our fans at home can
maybe try this out as well well you know
I think a lot of people that are here
are go
to get a chance to go and check out our
closed open uh sorry our closed beta
that's going to be happening format in
20 it's going to be happening on June 14
to the 16th but I believe over at the
madam booth we're giving out some codes
you guys may have seen it so if you
haven't checked it out go over to the
booth there's going to be a blog up I
believe many people's e-files is going
to go ahead and be talking about that
putting out check out our social
channels all that information is there I
brought a couple of codes here for juju
we're gonna give juju some codes as well
we're also going to be sharing on social
channels check that out a lot of great
information
you want some Adam Butte my are you sure
all right here you go but no it's
awesome but not just that but we're
gonna work with juju he's gonna be
giving out codes on his channel so again
tune in to our social channels all the
information there about the closed beta
happening on June 14th the June 16 but
since you're here you guys can grab it
early download it and get ready for June
14 all right thank you so much for
coming out Israel to to go play the game
go play they give it a round of applause
[Applause]
juju Smith Schuster there he goes
handing out those codes I don't know
that you're gonna get those back I don't
know if he's gonna all right well juju
is gonna go get a taste of what Madden
20 is all about but don't don't go
anywhere guys cuz we've got even more
Madden 20 gameplay to show you right now
cuz please welcome to the stage our
senior gameplay designer Clint Oldenburg
put it together everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
keep it going
gonna see you do it wonderful
oh my gosh thank you so much for being
here now we've seen those x-factor
abilities but I want to dig a little bit
deeper tell me a little bit more about
how they impact gameplay that's a great
question I'm gonna follow up with a
question for you for okay I'm trusting
you to give me the right answer you got
it what are some reasons you like to
watch football
I like yelling at my fantasy players
that's a good one okay anything else oh
you know what I like watching superstars
play like superstars but do you have
somebody like juju Smith Schuster I want
to see him make some big plays that's
exactly right
I'm sorry that you have to follow it it
was really hard assignment Trevor Noah
Jude you and now Clint Hey yeah yeah so
you mentioned superstars the NFL is such
a star driven league madden is no
different we set out with a creative
vision this year to make our stars feel
like stars so we created this ability
system known as super star X Factor's
these abilities are gonna bring
authentic skills that make these guys
feel unique and powerful so that every
individual game is unique and game plan
differently and that's what it's all
about authenticity and that's great that
you guys take that extra level of
realism can we see some more X factors
in action can we you know we talked
about mahomes at the start of the show
I'd love to see him go out there and do
his thing if that's pop yeah we got we
got some cool stuff to show you here
with Patrick mahomes our cover athlete
bazooka is his own ability now to get
into the zone you have to do an in-game
objective with mahomes you have to
complete four passes of 30 yards or more
and once you get inside the zone denoted
there by his x-factor icon he can throw
the ball further than anyone else in the
game his max past distances increased
about 15 yards to about 80 you can bomb
the floor
everybody's oohing and ahhing I mean
that's what we see on Sunday now you
talked about the air yards
it's got to be air yards right not
dumped on a mean Williams exactly four
passes of 30 yards or more that's
traveling in the air 30 yards so the
rack yards don't count and this all
makes sense because obviously mahomes
has a hell of an arm but can all
quarterbacks make throws like that or is
this just exclusive to him bazooka is
exclusive to Patrick mahomes I mean he's
got the big arm he's on record as
throwing an 83 yard pass we may be
selling him a little bit
listen this is not a gimmick ability
these things are inspired by their real
life skills that make them special so
that's his own ability does he have any
others yes he also has superstar
abilities as a neck as an x-factor one
of our better X factors he has a zone
ability and then superstar abilities
we're gonna break down his load out here
right here we got escape artist first
and as everyone knows he's a dual threat
quarterback escape artist gives him
elite agility and speed when scrambling
on passing the place looks like mahomes
right yes unfortunately I mean that's
what he does and a dashing dead I gives
him perfect passing accuracy when
throwing on the run so it's a nice
little combo there perfect passing
accuracies are the best accuracy you can
have in our game and then here's a red
zone yeah red zone Deadeye if you
watched him last year you know he was
deadly in the red zone when he's inside
the 20-yard line
again perfect passing accuracy lastly no
look that I'm really excited about this
one he's gonna have perfect accuracy the
only quarterback in the game that
launched have perfect accuracy on cross
body throws exclusive to him is the
no-look signature Mahone that's
animation that's his signature look
that's exactly what he does every Sunday
and everybody gets upset about it and
this is the thing though I know mahomes
I get it he plays like a star but come
on this is kind of a lot is he
unbeatable is there i if I'm on the
other side of the ball like what can I
do to stop them now you must play Madden
because that question our pets know it's
frustrating yeah it's a chess match so
just like in the NFL the way to shut
down a high power passing game is pass
rush the defense is gonna have knockout
conditions when these guys are in the
zone you're gonna see here mahomes with
his x-factor icon lit up he's in the
zone von Miller's gonna sack them the
objective for the Broncos in this game
sack mahomes knock him out of the zone
so each team's gonna have ways to
counter each other so again it's it's
it's authentic football conditions it's
a chess matches all that stuff exactly
and if you pull that objective off you
knock him out of the zone then he has to
go through his objectives again to get
back into the zone all right well that's
a little bit reassuring I'm glad that
there's some checks and balances that go
along with all that stuff but we all
know I know you're an offensive guy but
defense wins championships we've seen
what the offense can do well let's talk
about the defensive side of the ball you
know I want to see one of the most
incredible athletes in the NFL
regardless of position
Aaron Donald what's he all about yeah
Mary yeah give him a fair and Donald air
Donald is scary
so I played offensive line when I played
I knew I couldn't block him in this
chair
so he's reflected pretty well he's got
his own ability called fearmonger okay
what makes him special is when he gets
in the zone he can actually apply
pressure penalties to the quarterback
even when he's engaged in a block
typically those penalties only occur
when you're free rush unblocked to the
quarterback he does it while he's
blocked we're gonna take a look at some
of these he also has superstar abilities
he's out he's in the video there there
was the pressure penalty applied to the
quarterback right in addition to that he
has pass rush elite that's a superstar
ability that gives him quicker faster
pass rush ed moves as a pass rusher and
then under pressure makes those
penalties he's applying to the throw
power and throw accuracy the quarterback
more punitive so he's a quite a
disruptive pass rusher cuz that's one of
the things too it's not necessarily
especially with somebody who's playing
defensive tackle it's not somebody who's
always going out there and getting sacks
it's guys who are going out there and
also getting pressure up the middle
pushing offensive linemen into the face
of the quarterback yeah it lends itself
to more strategy in the game you got to
know who you're playing against you got
to know who you're playing with like I
said it's a chess match out there and
then one important note here with all
the passing abilities you said my home
seemed really powerful putting pressure
on the quarterback is going to be the
direct counter to a lot of those
abilities and that takes them off their
game and that takes them off an x-factor
and everything like that so it's good to
have those guys one of the cool things
too that I've noticed when you're
watching all that all the play and all
that stuff going on is that you've
worked really hard to bring these guys
unique abilities to life and put their
personalities out there and that
includes some custom animations so what
are some of the examples of these custom
animations you know these are super cool
we didn't want our superstars to just
feel great we want them to look great
too the first place is quarterback cover
athlete Patrick mahomes we went out and
captured these guys signature passing
animations we have covered for about six
to seven over the most popular
quarterbacks in the game we're going to
continue to add to these throughout the
year Aaron Rodgers quick release drew
brees you know he's always fidgeting if
you're a Saints fan and it's tense
beyond quarterbacks
everyone knows Zeke Eliot's feed me
getting the team in the zone these
animations you know celebrations throw
style
it's to connect with your favorite
players connect with your superstars on
the field what you saw I like why why we
saw the thing with Ezekiel Elliott
somebody who's a Cowboys fan or just
likes watching and play that they can
identify with they start cheering and
they like seeing that kind of stuff I
don't like seeing Aaron Rodgers leave
his feet and throw the ball 90 yards
down the field
but whatever we don't we don't have to
get into that Khalil max does you know
what we've talked a lot about the new
features what about player mechanics
because as a player what are like some
of the the tools in my toolbox so to
speak
nailed it with the toolbox yeah we're
always looking at ways to add new new
mechanics the game give our players more
control there's two that we want to go
over today and they're both for the
quarterback the first is the new
scramble mechanic or pull down mechanic
what this does is give you the ability
on a passing play to pull down the
passing icons with a button press become
a ball carrier all right full access to
all the spin moves Jukes ball carrier
moves and then you can bring back your
icons again with the same button press
and throwing at any time makes any
quarterback a dual threat bring some
skill here with Ben Roethlisberger we're
looking at the new pump fake mechanic
you can now pump fake to a specific
receiver on the hole but double tapping
the button you're gonna see the radical
come up to get guys to bite on it it
could dual purpose mechanic you can also
use it to pull down if you feel like
you've made a poor decision and you want
to cancel the throw just quickly double
tap it you'll pull it back down so you
can you know kind of pump make it to an
outside guy or then check it down to a
tight end or something like that
absolutely you can even use it on double
moves if you want juju to run a slant
and go okay
pump faking on the slant take him deep
oh that's amazing
there's mesquita and you know this she
played in the NFL not too long ago but
the game has changed so much in the in
the number of years since you've been
gone we've seen a lot of college coaches
come in and they brought in their
offenses and a most recently Kliff
Kingsbury down there in arizona bringing
in his high-powered offense
Kyler Murray you know not a prototypical
quarterback he's shorter but they're
gonna do a lot of that run-pass option
are you bringing that into the game yes
super excited to announce that we are
delivering our POS as they're known I
mean you know you can't watch an NFL
broadcast not hearing that acronym or
all they talk about 1314 times right so
this is a concept taking the entire
football world by storm we actually have
three different types of RP O's in our
game we have alert speaks and reads I'm
going to break those down really quick
for our players the first is an alert
that's a very basic pre-snap read you're
calling a running play and you're gonna
look at what the defense is aligned in
if you think you can run the play you
just call the play
you hit nothing you'll hand it off and
away you go however what's cool about
those places you can branch out of that
handoff at any time just by hitting the
receiver icon and throw it if he's open
so that's a really cool way to be
creative on offense and then there's two
other types that peak more similar to a
read option you're reading a single
defender on defense looking at his
behavior after the snap if he bites on
run you could pull it out throw to your
receiver and if he sits back on past you
just hold the button down hand it off to
the running back gain yards on the
ground
lastly the read this is more like the
traditional triple option play you're
gonna read two to three defenders after
the snap look at their behavior then
decide if you want to hand it off to
your running back keep it with your
quarterback or throw it to the receiver
we actually have over 200 RPO plays in
our play books to 220 that's a lot that
is very impressive and it sounds like
you've built in a lot more flexibility
are there any other formations or plays
coming to the game oh yeah you're gonna
see if there's any Eagles fans in here
you're gonna see something cool here in
a minute we got new animation technology
as part of our RPO story so we were able
to put in a lot of these cool concepts
you're seeing the NFL right now Philly
special is in the game pants on the game
play right here there it is right there
we also have a lot of jet sweet touch
pass concept you're seeing the Chiefs
and the Rams teams like that using end
arounds you're gonna see a lot of fresh
unique content in the play books and the
cool thing is we're gonna be updating
the play books all season long to make
sure that we're staying up-to-date with
the NFL this is all amazing thank you so
much Glenn I cannot wait for this game
we've we've dropped a lot of awesome
info here about Madden 20 here at EA
play that's what I say once again I'm
Adam rank if you want even more mad in
20 News you can tune in to the Madden
Channel right after this but before we
finish up though I've got one last treat
for you player ratings they're one of
the trickiest things to get right in
Madden well in addition to being a game
designer Clint uses his background as a
former NFL player to help make sure that
those ratings are accurate and our
friends over at ESPN have helped to put
together a little video to give us the
scoop on the
best job in the world the Madden ratings
adjuster let's roll it this is good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a 90 over rock my bad Rayden is horrible
it's try we're trying to make our game
match what these players are doing in
real life I would like safe one barkis
jump to the accurately rated you be like
93 94 if they think that we have it
wrong they're gonna let us know back to
the 90s
thank you Mike Epps Reagan gotta go up a
little bit I can't be dropping pics on
that I need my speed up just turn the
lights up a little bit for you
come on sucks who does my man ratings
[Applause]
I'm Clint Oldenburg I'm a madman rating
performance adjuster
[Music]